welcome back I'm stopping you people
stop it
all right will Hollywood learn what it
means to get replaced by machines
Tinseltown goes on strike so they won't
be replaced by lookalikes
sag aftra
that's a great name
there's a joke in there about Joy Behar
but I'm gonna let it pass
the labor union representing actors
announced yesterday that they're going
on strike luckily the videos I'm
shooting in Tijuana are non-union
but they now join the writers Union
which has been on strike since May and
writers are so broke now they have to
steal Adderall for middle schoolers
first time since 1960 that actors and
writers joined forces to shut down
Hollywood so what's driving this well
there's no standard in how people are
paid when their content is licensed to
streaming services which reminds me I
need to ask camera again for his Netflix
password
[Applause]
I think it's hot buns 300.
another major issue is how Studios might
use AI to replace human workers or even
non-human workers
her Native American name is sag aftra
it's close
writers fear it could be used to
generate scripts that are just as crappy
as theirs actors worry about their
likeness being copied and sold without
compensation the alliance of ocean
picture and TV producers even reportedly
proposed background actors having their
likenesses scanned they get paid once
and then the company gets to use it
forever for free
yeah it's actually not a new idea kill
me it's been appearing on Fox and
Friends that way for years
yeah
where's he from again massive Massapequa
yeah so we found that he's not the
serial killer
but on the bright side thousands of
Hollywood actors will now have more time
to take your order oh
Carly you know what's great about what
we do for a living and by we we really
mean me okay
we are in Irreplaceable right actors
you're just reading lines that's
replaceable that's why they should be
scared what do you thinking yeah because
you have personality and Pizzazz and a
robot that you never take that from you
yeah I think it's really cute that you
and Bill Hammer share a Netflix password
I didn't know that that's not all we
share that's adorable
um
so I actually just watched The Matrix
for the first time this week and I think
it's interesting that the one industry
that showed us what the robot take over
could look like could be the first
industry taken over by robots yes
um and what they are suggesting is
pretty wild that background actors could
be scanned and then an AI copy of them
could be used in all the scenes and I
actually could see why Studios would
like this because I used to audition to
be a background and commercial actor and
it's always the same thing you walk into
a big room and it's me and 250 other
women that look exactly like me and then
there's a casting director that spends
all day long just being like deliver the
line deliver the so this would save a
lot of time and a lot of money although
I am a no-go on the AI I want to live in
the real world and I think the actors
should keep their jobs now you were um
did you ever run into weirdo casting
agents that wanted no and I never booked
a job either a single one it's very
unsuccessful oh boy you're you're uh you
must have been one of the shorter people
there
because she's really tall you would know
she's sitting down which is extremely
tall so tall that when I raise my hand
you can't see my hand oh tap do you feed
you have sympathy for I'm putting my
hand down do you have sympathy for
Hollywood I kind of feel bad for them
but at the same time it's like you had
plenty of warning I don't feel bad for
him
um there's a lot to unpack here okay so
first of all
um I'm a partner in the AI company so I
have some background in this and to me
people have artificial intelligence
especially these people it's showing
that they don't exactly understand how
this works yeah um
it's like when the teacher said you had
a open notebook test but you decided not
to bring your notebook to the test right
like if AI is going to write the script
why didn't you just say hey guys let's
get together and have ai write the
script yes and we could still get paid
like yeah you know so AI should be it
should be an aid it should be something
that helps you it's not something that's
going to replace you and what I always
say I always say is um the infinite the
infiniteness of human consciousness is
more infinite than the machine the
machine is learning from us so without
our creativity and the infiniteness of
our creativity the machine can only
raise its level to us so the fact that
they're they're afraid of the machine is
basically opening up room for them to be
replaced by the machine because who's
going to write the scripts if you're not
there the machine's going to write this
yeah so fear fear says that they're they
they have they're scared because they
have a right to be scared but can can AI
actually learn also surpass the human
intelligence or will they actually learn
our own stupidity well it's definitely
learning on stupidity yeah
um it can never surpass us the AI Can it
can only thing to do is just do
calculations faster than us right it's
going to be good at math it's going to
be good at science but computers have
always been better uh than us at that
stuff but with AI I just look at it like
a tool to make humans do their job
better faster yeah so if I was in charge
of the union and everybody was like Hey
we're going to strike them that's a
pretty bad idea I'm gonna stay here and
I'm gonna do all of you guys jobs with
the AI right you know so I think you
just sit down and learn how to write AI
prompts AI cat could be our slave
um
about the face that I made was very
interesting it made me a little
uncomfortable yeah I looked away pretty
quickly I try yeah I try that at airport
bars uh and it doesn't okay yeah yeah I
I look I I guess I mean there's certain
things they could do for us I don't
think this would be would ever be able
to completely replace humans being in
movies or humans being in TV shows
because part of the reason that people
like watching movies or like movie stars
or people on TV is that they're human
beings and they like to either really
like them or to really hate them right
like to project a lot of their own onto
a stranger they see on TV I I see you
guys by the way some of you out there
yeah uh and they will be able to do that
with the robot so I think that it won't
really take off doing the background
action I mean it's creepy and it's weird
and it's greedy but I think ultimately
our own creepiness as humans that seeks
that out in strangers I think that'll
win out in the end that's true I think
uh the human human beings are strange
animals I don't think there could be an
AI uh Jim Florentine
um I mean I don't know I mean maybe yeah
but look I'm in a sag after Union so are
you on strike
um well my joke's bombed tonight I
couldn't write any hahaha
you when you write a joke do you then
look in the mirror and call yourself a
scab
I did this morning I'm like I'm crossing
the picket line yeah I believe it
no I'm not fat because I work on this
show on Comedy Central called Crank
anchors so they are they're all on
strike now because the actors are out I
mean I make prank phone calls am I
really an actor
yeah I'm really not but I technically I
guess I am so I'm on strike because I
can I can't you know you are the Rosa
Parks of prank phone callers
I don't know if that makes sense but I'm
trying to figure out because you're on
strike but you were you're like a
protester I don't know what I'm saying
I'm pretty sure that was racism
that's a good news that's a good title
for a segment pretty sure this might be
right
but it does hurt the background actors
because he got like 100 to 200 a day I
used to do that back in the day and you
can make money doing that jump from set
to set I would never stayed a whole time
with the background because you have for
like 12 to 14 hours yeah so I would just
go with a friend me and my friend would
go and then he would just sign me out
I'd stay for like an hour and I'd take
the subway back I'm like I'm not hanging
and then he would sign me out I would
get paid so wow what a secret little
life yeah I'm not gonna stand there for
14 hours but they're going to wipe all
that out yeah and then it affects the
people the Wardrobe people that have to
dress the background actors so a lot of
people are going to lose their job
because that's right you don't have to
dress up AI but you know what if you can
write a better script in a computer that
you should be able to so yeah all right
well that's great good job guys thank
you
wow you really are on strike
I told you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else